in this video i'm going to try something
totally new i'm going to challenge
myself to design a style frame
in 30 minutes
hey there my name is cameron with motion
science and today i'm going to give
myself a challenge and that challenge is
to design a style frame in 30 minutes or
less now there's a whole process
involved whenever i create a style frame
from scratch and i don't know where to
start and i actually examine that
process very thoroughly in my course
called stylecraft so definitely check
that out if you're interested in the
process but today what i'm going to do
is i'm just going to start from scratch
i'm going to set a timer for 30 minutes
and i'm going to see how the style frame
turns out so let's get started
okay so i've always wanted to do a style
frame
in the vein of a surreal
collage i see a lot of this stuff on
social media so i figured i'd try my
hand at this so the first thing i do is
download
a couple images i really like this image
a lot so i'm using the pen tool to very
quickly
cut out
the two women in the water horizon line
give it a nice little feather
dropping a planet in the background
just to see what i can come up with
searching for additional
space imagery back here
the clock is ticking i know i have 30
minutes or less
and it's actually pretty fun to do this
that's the first time i've ever done
this so
putting the the space image in the water
trying to create a reflection here
of the galaxy in the water looking
pretty cool the edge of the
horizon is a little bit funky it's too
crisp it doesn't blend very well
so trying to blend the horizon in a
little bit better
playing around the image more
bring another mask into this horizon to
try and
feather the horizon a little bit this
works a little bit better
the coloring is really off so between
the two images the coloring doesn't look
so great so that's why i'm using curves
here to attempt to
re-colorize the images and now i'm using
sapphire film effect which is one of my
favorite effects to give like a color
grade to any composition it's a really
quick way to add color grade
and get some quick looks
now i'm trying some some different
imagery again in the background just
trying different things whenever i
design i like to try
as many different
visual ideas as possible so that's what
i'm doing here just downloading
importing quickly drag and drop
does it work does it not work
uh pretty quickly you're gonna know
what your intuition your design
intuition is telling you uh if
something's working or not so here i am
trying another image and trying to use
some distortion to make it look like a
reflection in the water again using
curves to color correct images to make
them blend better together
adjustment layers over the top adjusting
the film effect
that's looking pretty cool again every
time i look at the clock it just freaks
me out though i'm like running out of
time like what can i do really quickly
it's also you know like a little bit
nerve-wracking to show you guys this
process because i don't know if
anything's gonna
come out of this it's any good or if
it's just gonna completely suck so
here's another moon image i found that
looks pretty awesome i thought it could
probably be used for
any type of planet just not just the
moon so i colorized it a little bit more
on the green side then i tried the red
side purple
tried to position it above the water
like it was rising on the horizon
not working so great there's some weird
edges anytime i'm moving really quickly
like this
you know i'm missing out on some of the
little details the subtleties that need
to be adjusted to make this these style
frames look that much better
but again just trying out ideas
trying imagery
playing more with glows and lighting
and color correction and mats constantly
trying different mattes alpha matting
luma matting
just to see what's working also
positioning elements
in different places on the screen just
to see you know what's gonna work what's
not gonna work i really like the
position of the two girls in the water
so that's you know pretty much set in
stone so i have this
upper two thirds of the screen to work
with and that's what i'm playing around
with here with the different
galaxies and nebulas
and planets
now i'm starting to get closer here
i like the color
of the two women in the water at this
point like the the color grade
it's getting closer with the galaxy it's
getting closer with the planet
just trying to rotate
things around again it's just still
playing around with position
it's all about just playing around
having fun
seeing if something works
in one position if it doesn't work
trying it someplace else now i'm adding
some quick blur to kind of blur out some
of the imagery in the background i don't
want it to be crystal clear
it's going to look too fake right if
that planet's sitting way back in that
background and it's
clear
to the human eye
it needs to be have a little bit of
blurred to sit more comfortably in the
composite
again so now i found something i like so
now is the point where i'm starting to
fine tune positioning of the images of
the planet of the galaxy back there
and just
really honing in
on that look so i'm adjusting the blurs
i'm adjusting some of the glows i like
to use a lot of glow and lighting
effects in my work so i'm trying
different ideas here very quickly
going into chromatic aberration this is
always a fun effect to use i'm trying to
finish something out
in this one it works
okay
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
i turned it back off
went back and added some grain which is
something i like to
put over the top of my composites most
the time
again going back to glow see if i can
make it work or not
and uh again it's getting really really
close i'm almost out of time
coming up on
25 minutes which i finished this in 25
minutes and here we go
and we're going to call that good i hope
that you really enjoyed this lesson as
much as i loved teaching it so please
let me know if you have any questions in
the comments below i'd love to answer
them for you hit that like button if you
enjoyed this video and please subscribe
to this channel it helps other people
find this channel as well if you're
looking to upgrade your design skill set
master the art of style and execute like
a pro i have a course called stylecraft
that you can check out at
motionscience.tv you can also learn more
about this course by clicking the link
in the description below as always
thanks for watching my name is cameron
and this is motion science
[Music]
you